[Music]
excuse me before I get started I want
everyone's attention this is important
earlier today I was in my office I look
out the window and I see Kent walking
along and there's a friend like a
friendly guy I try and get his attention
out the window buddies just grooving to
his tunes having a good time in Kent
land can we have someone push it on this
and this is me trying to get his
attention
desperately can you push in here and no
no right here on my phone three three
get in there get in there
what there we go what
[Laughter]
just grooving along mr. natural feeling
no pain was that well your will you
listening to so when I thought you were
listening to my monologue last night
that was after okay he said fish not
cold fish beam hanging just beyond look
out everybody I might if you misbehave I
might record it and then got you I might
be standing by my window for hours at a
time just to call out to people and
people say yeah excuse me is that Kaley
Cuoco
Kaley look it's me or is it cou oko
[Music]
you